main calm human scum boy these uh these
Christmas episodes really come back to
back when you binge through this stuff
okay so the snowmen this was actually
quite an interesting one for me to
revisit because it's better than I
remember
despite the fact that there's still
quite a bit that I don't like about it
and also to cover my usual baseline the
vast majority of Christmas specials of
Doctor Who have a tone and a vibe that I
don't really care for this sort of
almost pantomime style very very light
things get things get a bit sillier and
my tolerance for Doctor Who being silly
it the Christmas episodes have a
tendency to overshoot that for me
that being said despite the
ridiculousness of killer snowmen but
then again really is it any more
ridiculous thing you know killer
mannequins killer trash cans and I mean
it's makes about as much sense as the
killer Santa robots from earlier or
Christmas specials so you know I can I
can rolled it but aside from them this
is actually pretty straightforward not
nearly as goofy and disposable feeling
as the Christmas specials usually end up
feeling for me so that was kind of nice
because I haven't revisited this thing
in quite some time Matt Smith is doing a
good job in his new look as portraying
the doctor in mourning and it's kind of
nice that it's it's similar to and yet
distinctly different from David Tennant
in mourning because David Tennant coming
off of
Rose being trapped in the other
dimension and also coming off having to
wipe Donna's memory was very morose you
know he would he would try and have fun
but you could tell he was in pain
underneath that Matt Smith is a little
bit more sort of embracing his pain is a
little bit more upfront by about it he's
not trying to bury it so it gives it a
different feel for how he's coping with
the loss than say we saw a lieutenant
which is good and interesting and works
I like the setting I'm a sucker for
Victorian England as a setting in
general doesn't always work for me but
broadly speaking I do enjoy it as a
setting so I appreciate that we get the
Pater Noster gang and they're just fun I
mean the highlight is Strax and I I'll
only mention this to acknowledge that I
will bring it up later which is that
Strax in many ways is responsible for
the joka fiying of the Sontarans as a
race and sort of the defanging of them
as a threat but that's an issue for a
little bit later on here in this story
he is a lot of fun he is funny and
enjoyable and I love these always we
convert excuse to have to have grenades
around he keeps grabbing the memory worm
without the gauntlet so he keeps
forgetting why he has the worm I'd I
they're very basic jokes but they're
rooted in the kind of character he is it
feels true to him as a person so it's
less like a ridiculous pratfall and more
like a he's just so out of his element
this is gonna keep happening isn't it we
also get Madame vastra and Jenny who I
like but don't at least I feel don't get
as much of a highlight and this
certainly not as much as Strax does he
really gets a chance to shine here and
this one which I which I appreciate
quite a bit we have Richard II grant as
dr. Simeon he's pretty good he's
underutilized which is something that
will get made up for in actually the
very next episode so I guess or at least
we'll start
for in the very next episode so I guess
we'll come back to that but he Richard
he grant gives good ghoul so you know
he's he's got a good a good look for
believably being someone who has hated
other people since childhood and still
does and then we've also got the great
Sir Ian McKellen as the voice of the
intelligence the great intelligence
which is a it's a terrific callback I
hadn't I hadn't seen any of the things
with the great intelligence from the
classic era of when I back when I first
saw this when I won this first aired at
this point I have now seen oh what one
is is a web of fear I think is the one
in the London Underground with the yetis
and uh and that has the great
intelligence in it that I having now
seen that I have all the more reason to
appreciate that element of what's going
on here the killer snowmen are a little
bit ridiculous but again by the scaling
of especially the Christmas episodes for
Doctor Who no more so than any other
one-off villain for these kinds of
stories this is probably my favorite
iteration of Clara out of the three that
we get because we get we get Oswin we
get the this the governess car and then
we get the car or we actually travel
with and this was my favorite we learned
so much about her as a person in terms
of a personality and who she is and how
she operates and her sort of dual nature
in just the course of this one story we
get a sense of she hides her roots she's
oh she's more rough-and-tumble than she
likes to let on unless she's in a
setting where she's allowed to do that
in which case she just embraces it she
is thoughtful she is observant she is
good with kids we get a lot of things
that really give us a sense of who she
is a as a person I would actually argue
more so than we get with
the car we actually sick with but we'll
come back to that I actually like this
version of Clara
I think she's quite good and I I do kind
of like the the sort of magical realism
Dickensian vibe of things like the
TARDIS sitting on a cloud and you know
her using the umbrella to pull down the
ladder I enjoy that quite a bit the kids
aren't annoying that's nice
they're not great but they're not
annoying kids often can be so that works
I'm fine there so with all the stuff
that is either decent or works quite
well for me what's the problem
well everything kind of starts to come
apart once the ice woman is introduced
not that's not the only thing actually
the first sign of trouble is this whole
one word test that vastra gives to Claro
which is just kind of weird on its face
that entire notion but the fact that the
word that she uses that kids to the
doctor on the case is Pond is very
stupid because I don't know why because
it's it's sheer bloody coincidence
it catches his attention because
obviously Amelia pond
but the fact that Cory's nowhere it had
nothing to do with them and given that
she doesn't know about the ponds it
strikes me as very odd that I mean look
I'm not to say that I could be up to the
challenge of finding a single word that
would convince the doctor that he needs
to help but why would she think pond of
all words would be it it's just it's
just such a massive coincidence that
actually pivots the entirety of the
doctors interest in the case so to speak
at all and that's that's a that's a slim
coincidence to be hanging that on so I
don't love that that's the first sign of
trouble though things are mostly okay
for a bit but then
like I said the the ice governess shows
up and she herself is she's fine it's I
suppose in a way and natural upscaling
from the snowmen themselves as far as a
threat goes but she's not this she's not
particularly particularly memorable in
terms of actions or what she does the
look is is fairly memorable but there
isn't a lot to her and then at that
point just the the story starts just
rolling downhill and trying to wrap up
so much and we have to cover the idea of
the great intelligence arguably isn't
even really a thing and it was just
Simeon reflected into it but now it
continues to exist even though Simeon
doesn't remember anymore and so then it
takes him over and like snow can
remember and all this stuff just starts
piling up on top of themselves and in a
way that loses the thread of what was
working up to that point because a big
part of what was working up to that
point was the character interactions it
was you know Jenny vastra and Strax it
was Clara bantering with the doctor that
was what was really enjoyable about the
episode but then once the plot really
kicks into high gear it loses sight of
the stuff that was really working for it
and I say it falls apart it doesn't
really I suppose it just loses track of
its strengths it had a lot more going
for it and it just kind of drops it and
just thunders forward with a fairly
standard generic way of going about
things like oh here the monsters aren't
crouching now the monster caught us go
confront big thing you know it's it's
pretty bog-standard and it loses some of
the unique charms that the the show had
had up to that point all that said I
think I may have been shortchanging this
episode a little bit in past it's better
than I remember
and the parts that are good are quite
good again mostly coming down to banter
and character dynamics they are good
they're light they are fun and in a way
that works for me better than most of
the Christmas specials so I don't know
when I'll do any kind of ranking of the
Christmas specials again but this will
probably move up a couple slots from
wherever it was last time I did it so I
think we'll wrap it up there for the
snowmen and yes even though I know he
now has the purple coat I don't have
that coat so I'm still gonna be in this
have you re watched it lately what did
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it but stuff
to do like subscribe share this around
that helps me out quite a bit and if you
really want to help out I also have a
patreon where you can help me cover my
bills and get this whole thing going
bigger and better in the future
hopefully but you also don't have to do
any of that because at the end of the
day you are the council I'm just running
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]